[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis Sonntagabend willkommen zu den
Nachrichten im Sport unter anderem die
bahnrad-wm-operativ zum Abschluss mit
der siebten Medaille für Deutschland
schönes Schlussbilanz schön benannt das
dann gleich unsere weiteren Themen
absolute Kontrolle china staatschefski
will auf dem Parteikongress seine Macht
weiter ausbauen
Streit über die Kohle mit knapper
Mehrheit stimmt der Grünen Parteitag
unter anderem für den längeren Betrieb
zweier Kohlekraftwerke
und Gefängnisbrand in Iran mindestens
vier inhaftierte sterben auf den Straßen
gehen die Proteste gegen das Regime
weiter
[Musik]
der chinesische Staatschef skising Ping
will mehr Geld fürs Militär setzt weiter
auf eine restriktive corona-politik und
erhebt Anspruch auf Taiwan das sind
einige der wichtigsten Punkte aus
schießgrundsatz Rede heute zur Eröffnung
des parteikongresses der Kommunisten
2012 kommt Ski an die Parteispitze wird
dann auch Staatspräsident seitdem baut
er seine Macht stetig aus er lässt
parteiinterne Widersacher wegsperren
richtet Partei und Staat auf sich aus
dann 2018 Ski schafft die Begrenzung auf
zwei Amtszeiten ab und macht damit den
Weg frei für eine Herrschaft auf
Lebenszeit jetzt lässt er sich für eine
dritte Amtszeit bestätigen aus Peking
Miriam Steimer
das einzige Geräusch das während der
Rede des Parteivorsitzenden zu hören ist
ist das Blättern bei mitlesen alle fünf
Jahre gibt es diesen Partei Kongress
heute ist es die Krönungszeremonie
verschieden ping und seine Ideologie er
hat die Partei umgebaut auf sich
zugeschnitten alle macht läuft bei ihm
zusammen
das hier ist die große shishow alles ist
vorher abgestimmt alle Posten schon
vergeben die Delegierten sind nur noch
dafür zuständig sie abzunicken und
dieser Machtdemonstration hieß ein
besonders pompösen Rahmen zu verleihen
absolute Kontrolle das ist hieß Ziel
über die Partei über sein ganzes Volk
über jedes Bild selbst der T-Service ist
eine Choreographie bei seiner Rede
feiert er sich selbst für seine Null
corvette-politik während Millionen
Chinesinnen und Chinesen gerade im
Lockdown sitzen oder mit den
wirtschaftlichen Folgen kämpfen
auf der Weltbühne will Chi an der
konfrontativen Politik gegenüber den USA
festhalten besonders großen Applaus
erntet er beim Thema Taiwan er
bekräftigt dass er die Wiedervereinigung
anstrebt wie er es nennt zunächst
friedlich
aber wir werden uns niemals dazu
verpflichten auf die Anwendung von
Gewalt zu verzichten
eine Woche dauert der Kongress hier hat
die Begrenzung auf zwei Amtszeiten
abgeschafft und will weitere fünf Jahre
Parteichef bleiben
[Applaus]
in Deutschland haben die Grünen heute
zum Abschluss ihres Parteitages in Bonn
hitzig über die Klimapolitik diskutiert
kritik gab es vor allem am Kompromiss
zum Kohleausstieg in Nordrhein-Westfalen
die Details von Patricia Wiedemeier
es ist der dritte Tag der Parteitag fast
beendet da sorgt das Thema Klima dann
doch noch für Streit Luisa Neubauer von
Fridays for future liest den Grünen die
Leviten fordert mehr für den Klimaschutz
zu tun es liegt an euch in der Koalition
die ökologischen Grenzen zu ziehen und
zu verteidigen als würde es um alles
gehen denn das tut es Kritik die die
grüne Bundesregierung nicht auf sich
sitzen lässt
wir haben auch nicht 50 Prozent im Bund
sondern wir sind in der Minderheit aber
aus der Minderheit heraus bewegen wir
die Dinge verändern die Dinge lasst uns
das bitte nicht vergessen
gemeint ist auch der mit RWE
ausgehandelte Kompromiss demnach darf
der Ort lützerath abgebaggert werden
dafür wird schon 2030 aus der Kohle
ausgestiegen die Grüne Jugend will diese
Vereinbarung kippenrad ist mehr als ein
Symbol es geht mehr um als das Dorf es
geht um die Kohle darunter und wenn wir
die verfeuern dann reißen wir unsere
Klimaziele Widerspruch vom
nordrhein-westfälischen Umweltminister
das ist der größte Erfolg von Bündnis 90
die Grünen in der Kohlepolitik und wir
sollen das Feiern als gemeinsamen Erfolg
von Grünen und klimabewegungen es wurde
eng es blieb spannend aber am Ende
konnte die Grüne Jugend sich nicht
durchsetzen
zwei Tage lang erkannte man die Partei
kaum wieder geschlossen kaum Streit
nicht so wie früher die Grünen stimmten
Waffenlieferungen in Krisengebiete und
längeren Atomlaufzeiten zu nur heute
beim ur-grünen Thema Klima da ging es
noch mal runter gab es heftige
Diskussionen aber auch am Ende dann
folgten sie den Vorschlägen des
Bundesvorstandes und der Landesregierung
hier in NRW dem Parteivorstand blieb
damit eine Schlappe erspart
im Iran spitzt sich die Lage offenbar zu
gestern spät abends brachen ein
berüchtigten Gefängnis Feuer aus
mindestens vier inhaftierte kamen ums
Leben etwa 60 wurden verletzt in der
Haftanstalt Evin wohl laut Augenzeugen
immer wieder politische Gefangene
gefoltert und misshandelt werden
innevinen werden auch Menschen
festgehalten die an den seit einem Monat
andauernden Protesten gegen die
Staatsführung teilgenommen hatten
Alexandra Vacano
Flammen und Rauchwolken über dem
Gefängnis eviden und immer wieder
Schüsse die Bilder sie werden
tausendfach in den sozialen Medien
geteilt auch diese hier rund um die
Haftanstalt Staus und Proteste sie rufen
Tod dem Diktator Tod für Harmony und sie
Hupen als Zeichen der Solidarität mit
allen Demonstrierenden
am Tag danach das Feuer ist gelöscht
Ruhe sei eingekehrt will das iranische
Fernsehen zeigen nein mit den
Massenprotesten hätte das hier nicht zu
tun mein Teheran der Gouverneur der
Stadt sagt dieses Feuer wurde durch
einen Kampf zwischen einigen Gefangenen
in einer Nähwerkstatt verursacht
das wirklich hinter den Gefängnismauern
passierte völlig unklar klar dagegen
Evin ist eine Haftanstalt mit
schlimmsten Bedingungen wie Bilder aus
den Überwachungskameras zeigen
Menschenrechtler prangern immer wieder
Misshandlungen an denke dass dieser
Gefängnisbrand von sehr hoher
symbolischer Bedeutung ist unabhängig
davon wer ihn ausgelöst hat denn er
wirft ein Licht auf die Situation
politische Gefangene ganz normaler
Demonstranten Jugendlicher im Iran und
deswegen denke ich es ist recht
wahrscheinlich dass er die Proteste eher
noch befeuern wird seit vier Wochen nun
fordern mutige Iranerinnen und Iraner
das Regime heraus
sind ganz viele unterschiedliche Gruppen
und Schichten die sich hier synchron
verhalten die sich nicht organisieren
aber die auf die Straße gehen zur selben
Zeit und ein ähnliches oder sogar gleich
geartetes Ziel verfolgen nämlich die
Abschaffung der Islamischen Republik in
ihrem gegenwärtigen System nieder mit
der Islamischen Republik nein zum
Diktator heißt es auch vor der
iranischen Botschaft heute in Berlin
in Paris haben 10.000 Menschen gegen die
Regierung von Präsident macron
demonstriert besonders großen Unmut gibt
es wegen der gestiegenen Preise außerdem
herrscht an vielen Tankstellen
Spritmangel weil das Personal in den
Raffinerien streikt zu den Protesten
aufgerufen hatte das französische
Linksbündnis die Regierung befürchtet
die Spannungen könnten eine neue
Protestwelle hervorrufen
willkommen zum Sport heute sind die
Bahnrad Weltmeisterschaften zu Ende
gegangen und ja wirklich mit einem
goldenen Finale für Deutschland noch und
damit auch mit einer beeindruckenden
Schlussabrechnung denn durch den
heutigen WM Triumph von Lea Sophie
Friedrich im Keilriemen bringt das
deutsche Team insgesamt dreimal Gold
dreimal Silber und einmal Bronze mit
nach Hause aus serkonterin
nach dem 7 WM-Titel ihrer noch jungen
Karriere ringt Lea Sophie Friedrich
Umfassung
ich kann es gar nicht glauben im
Keilriemen Finale liefert sich die
22-Jährige aus das so ein
atemberaubendes Duell mit der Japanerin
Nina Sato in der letzten von sechs
Runden zieht Friedrich vorbei und
gewinnt damit zum zweiten Mal Gold auf
der Olympiabahn von Paris 2024
mit zwei Treffern von Stefan Tigges
gewinnt der 1 fC Köln das erste
Sonntagsspiel der Bundesliga gegen
Augsburg mit 3:2 und klettert vorläufig
auf Platz 7 und der Classico das ewig
junge fußball-duell zwischen Real Madrid
und dem FC Barcelona Ausgabe Nummer 185
heute im Kampf um die Tabellenführung
und das Gewinnen daheim die Königlichen
natürlich ganz in weiß
Real Madrid empfängt den FC Barcelona
beide Teams ja punktgleich in der
Tabelle Toni Kroos mit einem ersten
Highlight zwei Kampf gewonnen gegen
bußkette und Traumpass auf Vinicius den
Abpraller verwandelt Karim Benzema heute
Torschütze der Franzose Montag
wahrscheinlich Gewinner des Balance
läuft für Real 35 Minute weil werde zu
viel Platz gutes Auge Halbzeitstand 20
real in der zweiten Halbzeit Barcelona
stärker Lewandowski eigentlich
abgemeldet hier gibt's keinen Elfmeter
für den Polen Barcelona aber kann
verkürzen Ferran Torres 83 Minute
Nachspielzeit jetzt gibt es den Elfmeter
aber auf der anderen Seite Rodrigo
gefoult er verwandelt entstand 3:1 die
Königlichen Drohnen in Spanien an der
Tabellenspitze
ja immer wieder faszinierend der
Klassiker danke Norbert und jetzt haben
wir noch eine kuschelige Nachricht aus
Großbritannien für sie ein kurzer Besuch
bei Königin Camilla dann gehen mehr als
1.000 Paddington Bären und andere Teddys
frisch geschrubbt an eine
Kinderhilfsorganisation nach dem Tod der
Queen hatten viele Trauernde die Bären
vor den Schlössern abgelegt
Paddington und die Queen hatten eine
ganz besondere Beziehung in diesen
millionenfach geklickten Video verrät
sie den Bären dass sie in ihrer
Handtasche stets ein Marmeladen Sandwich
mit sich trage
[Musik]
der Blick aufs Wetter im Nordwesten
dichte Wolken ab Mittag dann regen und
einzelne Gewitter in der Südosthälfte
erst Nebel dann länger sonnig 17 bis 26
Grad
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um 21.45
zum heute-journal und jetzt geht es hier
weiter mit Berlin direkt und Theo Koll